hey there it's Cameron with motion
science and I'm here today to talk to
you about my story why am I telling my
story well I want to tell you my story
because I get asked all the time did I
go to art school and my self taught you
know how have I been had this talent all
my life was I just a natural at doing
motion design and the the simple answer
is no I haven't done this all my life I
am self-taught and I started from no
background in art so I'm here to tell
you today that you can do exactly what
I'm doing you can be a pro motion
designer and I'm gonna tell you how I
got to where I am today
[Music]
okay so let's talk about my story so
what is my story well it's kind of a
long story
but all starts beginning back in the day
when I was a young adolescent I always
want to be a film director and that
meant that I wanted to be making movies
and feature films like Steven Spielberg
directors like that really inspired me I
remember also directors like Tim Burton
timber was a big inspiration for me and
I wanted to I thought you know make my
own feature film so I would write
screenplays and I would make little
films in my backyard at my house with my
friends and we just we created little
films and I had a great time I do it for
school projects or I just do them from
my own personal tastes and or my own
what's the word just because I wanted to
write just to experiment and have fun
and so I started doing that when I was
an adolescent I got into high school and
in high school I had my heart broken by
a girl and when that happened I decided
to make a like a music video about how I
was feeling I wanted to express myself
and I didn't know how to do that so
music has always been a huge inspiration
for me so I set out with some my friends
and I kind of just created a music video
I took a popular song that was on the
radio and I took that song and I put
visuals to it and I spent weeks several
weeks and I actually shot all this
footage with my friends and then I went
back and I actually hired a professional
editor and I paid him a several hundred
dollars which you know to a high school
students quite a bit of money and we
made this music video and I got a lot of
really great response from it so I
actually entered it into a film festival
and lo and behold of the film festival I
won like first first place I got a prize
and I got some accolades from some
difference editors that came in from
Hollywood now mind you I lived in Kansas
at this time so it was a big deal I was
like you know just getting this this
recognition that's praise for my talent
was a huge deal to me so I thought
I'm pretty good at this so end of high
school I applied to go to college USC in
Southern California at the time I don't
know if it still is but at the time it
was like the number one film school in
the country
I applied to USC and I applied to NYU
the two top film schools well what
happened was NYU
sends me a letter they reject me pretty
down the dumb so I get my letter from
USC kind of expecting the same thing and
lo and behold they accepted me into
their film program and I was shocked but
I did know I had a talent right just a
visual talent for creating visual things
so I kind of freaked out about the cost
of going to USC at the time I don't know
how much it was but I was a very low
middle-class family and my parents
really couldn't help me out they pretty
much say like we can't help you out you
gotta figure this out on your own and
when the costs kind of was tallied
together I freaked out and I just didn't
go to college now mind you I had gone to
private school all my life going to
college was like the next step that you
take and all my friends went to college
so they all left for college I stayed
behind and I felt I mean honestly I feel
like a failure and I think to some of
them they kind of viewed me as like man
that guy had a lot of talent it's too
bad it's unfortunate he's getting left
behind
so what happened next was I decided to
just pick up and move to LA like I said
I was from Kansas small town Wichita and
I moved to LA with the hopes of working
for films and maybe becoming a director
while lived in LA for a year and I was
very kind of put put off by the whole
system the directing system I worked on
a lot of independent films we've done a
couple big big blockbuster films got to
work with Tim Burton which was pretty
cool just as a location assistant so I
wasn't like I was directing but Tim
Burton but I got to you know see him in
action it was pretty awesome to see all
that stuff but I ran out of money
basically is what happened in LA it's
very expensive to live
I didn't make very much at all working
on feature films and as a PA so I had to
move back to Wichita after one year in
LA and that was another like big shock
to my system another failure right it
was just like man I didn't go to college
I moved to LA I think I'd make it there
didn't make it I'm back in my hometown I
actually moved back in with my parents
and I just felt pretty down in the dumps
about myself so I always had this plan
that was just gonna spend a few months
back at home make some money I had a
friend who arranged a job for me make
the money go back to LA do my thing well
I met a girl and fell in love with this
girl and lo and behold before we knew it
within a few months we were expecting a
baby and as you can imagine my life
really flipped upside down at that point
and so I couldn't go back to LA I had to
do the right thing and support my son
and this woman I fell in love with and
so the next thing I know I'm having a
baby well you know being a young dad I
think I was 23 at this point and had
this little baby and a friend of mine
offers me a position at a TV station in
Wichita and this was a Fox affiliate
station and you know it was a great
opportunity and that's why I took it
because all of a sudden here I was I was
a director I was a writer I was a
producer and I was a camera operator and
I was an editor right and these five
things like they all filmed this one
role for me and there was me and like a
couple other people that had this this
role and we got to make commercials for
different local clients to the Wichita
area so Wichita is a town of like
400,000 people lots of car dealerships
and pawn shops and and little
mom-and-pop shops and so that's who I
was making commercials for it was
nothing super exciting at the time I was
proud of it cuz I was making you know
was gonna be creative I was getting to
write these
and the budgets for these projects were
low like $500 right and and the client
would spend $500 thinking like that was
the be-all end-all budget paying you so
much to do this project you got to make
it look awesome I was also working for
like attorneys and and pawnshops and
things like that things like that
weren't necessarily like the highest
caliber of clients but I got a lot of
opportunity well during this time I
think I was there for two years during
this time one of my buddies there
introduced me to After Effects and he
was really intrigued by it and I was too
I was just like wow this is really cool
I had never heard of motion graphics
when I lived in LA motion graphics
wasn't a thing yet and so I I start
playing about After Effects and I was
just I was so fascinated by it that
before I knew it I bought myself a Mac
an Apple computer at my house and at
night so I'd worked her in the day I'd
come home and I'd take care of my son my
wife would then go off to work we're
trying to make ends meet
as soon as my son go to bed I would stay
up late late into the night working on
projects and After Effects and a 3d
program called Lightwave and I just
started creating as much as I could I
was so fascinated by the process I just
wanted to know how to create how to make
logo animations how to make visual
effects how to make type move how to
make squares move I'm just you know how
to effect footage all these different
things that became part of what motion
graphics is today so I spent a good
amount of time maybe about a year I
think working figure out After Effects
I'm building my little reel it was all
spec work I'm a big fan of spec work I
believe that spec work for yourself
enables you to create the type of work
that you want more of I don't believe in
creating spec work for somebody else for
free that's a whole different topic but
for creating spec work for yourself it's
an amazing opportunity to create the
type of work that you want to get the
type of work that fulfills you
creatively is when you create an spec
work so I created a demo reel
and I sent this demo reel off to a big
production house
hanza City so which shows in the middle
of Kansas Kansas cities up on the top
right corner of Kansas it's split
between Kansas and Missouri and this
production house called me up and said
hey we'll do an interview with you want
to talk to you and I was so excited so I
couldn't tell my current position TV job
that I was going to go interview in
Kansas City I didn't want them to think
I'm looking for another job so kept
under the radar
got the interview set up for like 8 a.m.
in the morning so I left at 5:30 in the
morning one day drove to Kansas City
it's two and a half hours away showed up
at 8 a.m. for my interview and I was sat
down with a producer and told that hey
let's take a look at your reel we
haven't even looked at your stuff yet
let's see what you got and when they
said that I was just like are you
kidding me
like I just drove two and a half hours
super early in the morning to be here
assuming that you had taken a look at my
reel you were interested in my talent
you know what good so they watched my
demo reel they're like okay great you
know you've got some talent but we don't
own any positions for motion graphic
artists thanks for being here what okay
so I raced back to to Wichita telling my
job lunch so I'm gonna be you know late
coming in so I get back and I do my
stuff well I make another reel I create
more spec work make another reel one
year later well six months later that
same company in Kansas City sees my new
reel that I had sent to them and they
said hey by the way we we checked it out
we were very serious about you coming up
here come on up so I came up they hired
me on the spot went back to Wichita gave
my notice moved my entire family to
Kansas City and now I had moved so I'd
moved from a local small town doing pawn
shop commercials I had done moved up to
regional work now okay so now I'm doing
a regional work in Kansas City I'm doing
work for the Midwest working on lottery
commercials I'm working on campaign
videos and commercials I'm working on
commercials for like companies like
Sprint
who are based in the Midwest you know
just a lot more interesting work that
pushed me a little bit more in terms
about creative abilities and I did that
for two years again two years but about
18 months into that job I started
feeling like okay I there's more authors
more I can do there's more my potential
is more than this so what happens is I
create more spec work again I take my
work from the regional work I was doing
plus I take the spec work I'm creating I
put a new reel together and it's like 60
90 seconds long I put this real online I
send it to one person now one person's
name is Kyle Cooper and he immediately
gets on the phone calls me and asked if
I can do remote work for him working on
some spots for HBO well of course I was
immediately oh yeah of course I mean
you're Kyle Cooper you're the guy who
changed everything for me when I saw the
movie se7en right so Kyle Cooper was
involved in the title sequences of seven
and in in my opinion that really changed
motion graphics and it propelled it into
the mainstream media with things like
title sequences right before that point
there were motion graphic title
sequences but nothing that really kind
of gave you that that wow factor like
seven did so next thing I know I'm
freelancing for Kyle Cooper for prologue
films at night at night okay so I am
working 8:00 to 5:00 at my job coming
home and working like 6 or 7 p.m. until
sometimes to 3 o'clock in the morning
for prologue films and now something I
forgot to mention is during this time
I'm going through a divorce right so the
thing with the woman I would fall in
love with just didn't work out and we're
separated so I'm a single dad at this
point so I have my kids one week on one
week off well I'm taking care of my kids
when I can
working my butt off I remember one night
working until 6 o'clock in the morning
going to bed until 7:30 getting up
taking my kids to school going back to
my day job and then just repeating so
what happened was I'm doing this for
like a couple months and one day a
producer at the job I'm at sees me
working on this stuff and she kind of
runs off and tattles
to the owner of the company next thing I
know under the company says you can
either do one of two things you can give
us a cut of your freelance work that
you're working on or or you can walk out
the door right now which I was like are
you kidding me like why would I give you
a cut of my freelance work it's at night
it's a different companies LA we're in
Kansas City there's no competition here
so I walked out the door and at that
moment I became a full-time freelancer
okay so I was fortunate enough that I
continued to get work from prologue
films for weeks and weeks and weeks I
also had some other clients start kind
of slowly coming in I was doing a whole
animation type work right and then one
day a company called digital kitchen
calls me up and says hey we love your
work you saw your reel would you use
some style frames for us and I'm like I
know what style frames are but I I'm not
a designer
I've never taken in our class I've never
taken a drawing class no type of art
class ever even in high school I would
typically do the more academic based
programs versus like the more fun free
program or the more fun artistic
programs I did some theater and things
like that but I was scared to death
honestly so scared to death I'm like I
know I was just straight-up with them
and that's the thing when you freelance
you need to be honest with people
upfront with people so I just told the
creative director I said hey listen man
like I've never designed stuff frames
before I don't even know how to do this
and he was straight up with me and he
believed me and he said you know what
Cameron he's
I've seen your work I've seen your
animation I've seen how you can post
things you can do this so I put together
my first set of frames I believe is for
Verizon maybe the the cell phone company
and I you know I spent several days on
these frames and I reluctantly handed
them off thinking they're gonna say well
you know they're okay but to my
amazement they loved what I did the
client Verizon actually picked my frames
to move forward with it with and the
next thing I know I'm now a motion
designer a true motion designer I'm I'm
animating I'm also designing and that's
something else we'll talk about in a
future video is that I believe as a
motion designer generalist which many of
us are you need to understand motion as
well as design it's very important that
you understand design as well so from
there it just it took off I just I
continue to freelance I continue to be a
remote artist it was very important to
me to be able to stay in Kansas City
with my kids I had two kids at this
point and just to be a very present
father to them so I continued my remote
freelance career every one small I would
travel to a city to work for a new
production company once they realized my
talent and who I was and I was a
reliable person they would then come
back to me and continue to give me
remote work you know month after month
so I continued to remote freelance I
mean that was in 2007
no one was was doing it at the time or
very few people were doing at the time
and it just took off from there and I
could just continued over the years to
hone my skills to you know just really
improve my skills and that came from me
just working on a variety of types of
projects from projects where I was only
animating our projects where I was only
designing our projects where I was doing
both there was projects where I was in
charge of the overall creativity of a
project and there was projects were only
worked on you know five seconds of a
piece and I was just part of a team it
didn't matter because I just continued
to do what I could do best
that is the moral I guess the moral of
the story is and this is a long story
about my my journey but it's that
anybody can do this if you put in the
time and you put in the effort and you
just you push yourself and you get
uncomfortable and you do things that
scare you
you will become a amazing motion
designer you just have to put in the
time I see a lot of motion designers who
just they want that instant satisfaction
they think that if they learned this
program or this program or this program
that that's the key now you need to
understand motion and design you need to
just dive in the trenches you need to
experiment push yourself creatively and
you will get there and I mean I'm
testament to that I also have other
motion designer friends who have very
similar stories who just kind of came up
from from nowhere and became amazing
artists so you don't have to have the
traditional art school you don't have to
know how to draw you do have to
understand some basic concepts of design
to become an amazing motion designer but
you can do it so hopefully my story will
help you feel inspired to think that you
can and to know that you can do it and
that's all I've got for you today thanks
for taking the time to watch this video
there's gonna be more of these coming
out very soon until next time I'm
Cameron and this is motion science
[Music]